ADAM STEWART: Welcome to
Musicians at Google.
I am Adam Stewart, and
I'm very proud to
introduce John Taylor.
John is the bass player of Duran
Duran, founding member
of the iconic British band that
was actually referred to
as the Fab Five.
So if you're going to get a
compliment, get compared to
the Fab Four, for sure.
John's book came out on
Tuesday the 16th.
"In the Pleasure Groove: Love,
Death, and Duran Duran." I
highly recommend the book.
The book has been the best
seller in the UK, where it was
released a couple weeks ago.
Currently number six
on the New York
Times bestseller list.
So what we're going to do today
is John and I will talk
a little bit, and then John's
also going to read a couple
passages from the books.
John will stay afterwards to
sign a book, so they're
sitting outside, so please
be sure to get
a copy of the book.
And just a couple of requests.
We ask no flash photography
or recording, and
if you could, everyone--
I know this is hard to
do at Google-- please
silence your phones.
John, 1978 was the year that
Duran Duran was formed, and
you have an amazing career.
What made you decide to
write the book at this
point in your life?
JOHN TAYLOR: A couple
of things.
On the one hand, I lost my dad
coming up on three years ago
this Christmas, and he passed
away in the house
that I grew up in.
And I sold the house, drove away
from the neighborhood.
He was the last of
his generation.
I mean, I live in the fast lane,
like all of us here, and
I find that constantly, I have
to really fight to hold onto
my memory these days, because
there's so much information
coming at me.
And I found that from the moment
my dad was buried, the
forgetting what was happening
so quickly.
And so that kind of motivated
me to think about
memorializing my parents
in some way.
I wasn't quite sure what that
was going to be, but I'm an
artist, so it's natural.
I was thinking, should I
write some songs, or--
I didn't know what it
was going to be.
And then I was approached,
actually, at the
beginning of last year.
There's been quite a boom in
music memoirs in the last
couple years.
We've got Keith Richards
to thank for that.
And I was approached by an agent
in London who said, if
you were to be interested in
writing a book, this would be
a really good time.
And I thought, well, maybe
that's what it is.
So I kind of started formulating
the idea for the
book, which is kind
of in three parts.
There's growing up in the '60s
in the Midlands of England and
becoming John.
And then the second section of
the book's hysteria, and
that's really about the first
five years of the '80s and
this wild ride that
Duran Duran took.
And then the third part of the
book is the bit I call
becoming an adult human being,
and that's really been some of
the more profound highlights
of the
last 15 years, I suppose--
losing parents, gaining
children, marriages, divorces,
all of that sort of stuff.
Real life stuff, but through
the lens of an ex-pop star.
ADAM STEWART: Could you talk a
little bit about your process
for the book?
I know you partnered with Tom
Sykes, and Tom's a freelance
journalist, "Men's Health,"
"GQ," a bunch of other
publications.
And at the same time, you're
going back 30 plus years, and
you've got all of these things,
and the book really
kind of tells a chronological
story, as you mentioned.
So how did that all
come together?
JOHN TAYLOR: Well, when I did
move everything out of my
parents' house, I did come
out with a dozen boxes of
memorabilia from my early life,
which I thought a lot of
it was just gold.
I thought, wow, I've got to
use this for something.
So I knew that I was
going to have some
really, really good evidence.
I had to sift through that,
and sort of organize it.
Tom Sykes, you mentioned, he's
the ghost writer on the book,
and he was fantastic.
I don't think I could have
done it without him.
I thanked him in the back of the
book for holding the torch
steady as we went through
the attics.
And he just kept me rolling.
We couldn't descend
into neuroses.
Once we made the decision to do
it, and we had a schedule,
and we had to stick to it.
And there was a couple of times
I thought, what am I
doing this for?
I knew I was going to have
to get into some
kind of murky stuff.
It wasn't all going
to be happy.
But I felt that for the book
to have any sense of
authenticity to it, it was going
to have to touch on some
of the darker sides
of success.
But yeah, we had a pretty good
working ethic, and when things
got really tough, we'd just get
on our bikes and go for a
ride, burn it off.
ADAM STEWART: Sources
of inspiration
while you were writing.
Were you going back
and listening
to some of the music?
Were you reading something
in particular?
I know you mentioned Keith's
book, although I think your
book takes a different tone,
because Keith dishes a lot on
his bandmates.
And you didn't necessarily
take that tactic.
JOHN TAYLOR: Well, I've
read a lot of books.
I've read a lot of books.
I'm a huge fan, first, of
popular culture, so I've read
a lot of books over the years.
And generally, the better books
about music are written
by writers.
But there are one or two memoirs
that really work.
I mean, actually, I remember
when I was about 14, Ian
Hunter, who was the singer with
Mott the Hoople, and he
wrote this book called "Diary of
a Rock and Roll Star." And
it was a very pragmatic, day
by day breakdown of what a
band did when it was on
the road in America.
It wasn't a sex, drugs, and
rock and roll thing.
It was just really basic.
But to me, wow, it was just so
glamorous and evocative.
I mean, it was all about
finding a voice.
I mean, I guess I've done enough
blogging, and I've done
enough interviews to know that
when I'm in the mood, I can
tell a story well.
It's just finding the way to
put that down to actually
record that in the computer.
And once we got the right
attitude, the right tempo, it
all started to flow.
ADAM STEWART: What do you think
might be the biggest
surprise for someone who
picks up the book?
JOHN TAYLOR: I think there's a
number of surprises in there.
I mean, it's not just
about fame.
It's not just about,
well, we did this,
and then we did that.
It's a very personal,
very human account.
Frank is a word that is used
to describe it a lot.
I mean, it's a coming of age
book, in a way, and I was able
to disconnect from the character
quite a bit, really,
because just watching this
little kid, an only child,
mother raging Catholicholic took
him to church every day
of his life for the first
five years, and
how he got into music.
How music just took
over for him.
But I mean, I didn't have the
kind of parents that made me
take piano lessons.
My parents were completely
clueless when it came to
school and education.
I had to find it for myself.
And it was at that time, 12,
13, 14, where the desire to
remake my identity was so
strong, and music at that time
in the UK--
we were talking about
this earlier--
I mean, there were a lot
of very, very strong
personalities.
David Bowie, Freddie Mercury,
Rod Stewart, Bryan Ferry.
I mean, these guys
coming out--
I mean, I'm not going to say was
a golden age, but it was a
very strong age in terms
of personalities.
And for a kid that was just
not really connecting in
school, was an only child, I
just started connecting with
these guys in a big way.
And even though I couldn't play
an instrument, I just
wanted to be in that club.
And so by the time I was
17, I knew that's
what I wanted to do.
ADAM STEWART: So your career is
really amazing, and I think
when people look at a career
like yours, they think--
there's probably three things.
Is it luck, is it timing,
or is it hard work?
JOHN TAYLOR: Yeah.
Well, I think also, part of the
book is demystifying that.
I mean, a lot of collaborators,
people come and
they work with us, and they're
looking for the magic.
They're looking for how did you
guys-- what do you guys--
what's the thing?
And it's like, you
just show up.
You just show up at the
studio and start
hitting chords around.
I mean, I was humbled, actually,
looking at the--
I really got into the first few
years of the '80s, because
apart from the fact it was a
fantastic time to be in Duran
Duran, I think it was a really
great time for pop culture,
and a very under-appreciated
time in the culture.
I mean, maybe we'll start
looking at it more as the
beginning of techno.
It was the period when fashion,
photography, video,
things were starting to connect
in music in a more
formal way.
It was a renaissance
time, in a way.
And I really wanted
to look at that.
And I don't write about
it in any great
depth, but it's there.
I was humbled by the amount
of work we did, man.
Oh my god.
I mean, the funniest thing,
actually-- it was 1982, which
was the year of "Rio." And we
were in the studio in London,
I think, for about two,
maybe three months
recording that album.
And we came out of Air Studios
and flew straight to Sri
Lanka, where we did videos for
"Hungry Like The Wolf," and
"Save A Prayer."
We went from there to Australia
for our first time,
and Australia was like
Beatlemania.
And then we went from there
to Japan, which was like
Beatlemania but with
Japanese accents.
Madness!
And then we came to America, and
America, obviously, is a
very hard territory to break.
Very, very hard.
And that summer, we really
went for it.
We crisscrossed the country
several times.
Fortunately, at the time, our
record company, Capital, was
being controlled by
the London office.
There are no American record
labels like that anymore.
So the London office was kicking
their asses every day
saying, you've got to break
this band, or we're
going to lose them.
So Capital were like, OK,
OK, what do we do?
And it was a massive campaign.
MTV started happening
at the same time.
We were seeing our ticket sales
and album sales were
coming up in states that
MTV was showing in.
We went back to Europe.
We did a victory lap of Britain
at the end of the
year, like November, House
Records in our home city.
And then I'm looking, and I've
got all this out, and I've got
the itineraries from back there,
and I see that we're at
the Holiday Inn in Birmingham
on December 1, 1982, and I'm
thinking, OK, so what
happens then.
After all of this, oh, I go
back to my parents' house,
because I'm still living
with my parents.
That's how crazy--
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN TAYLOR: But it happened
so fucking fast.
And there's nothing like
a father to bring you
back down to earth.
I think I'd been there two days
before he was, turn that
bloody music down!
You're not on bloody tour now!
And I really enjoyed--
and that was a discovery
for me.
I wouldn't have remembered
that if I
hadn't written a book.
And that was like, wow.
ADAM STEWART: That's amazing.
Why don't we, if you would,
want to take us through a
passage of the book?
JOHN TAYLOR: Sure.
Yeah.
I'm a little bit concerned that
some of the readings are
a bit long, so bear with me.
I'm going to read a little from
the first chapter, which
is called Hey Jude.
I'm four years old, confident
and shy, hair blonder than it
would be in my teen years, in
shorts and sandals, a young
prince of the neighborhood.
The south Birmingham suburb
of Hollywood.
How perfect.
10 o'clock in the morning on any
given weekday in 1964, and
I've stepped down off the porch
[? in wait, ?] kicking
at the grooved concrete
driveway, watching as mom
pulls the front door closed,
locks it up, and puts the key
in her handbag.
She puts the handbag in the
shopping bag, and off we go,
left off the drive and up the
hill that is the street on
which we live, Simon Road.
Our house is number 34, one up
from where the road ends.
We walk together along the
pavement, counting down.
32, 30, 28.
On the left side of the street
are all the even-numbered,
semi-detached houses, single
buildings designed to function
as two separate homes, houses
twinned with number 36.
Across the street, the odd
numbered houses are detached,
each building a single dwelling,
all much larger than
ours, and so are the back
gardens, which are long and
tree-filled, and bordered at
the bottom by a stream.
The driveways are slicker,
too, with space for
more than one car.
I hold mom's hand, remembering
the Beatles song that is so
often on the radio as the
incline gets steeper.
We reach the crest of the hill
where Simon Road meets Douglas
Road and turn right.
We pass a 12 foot high holly
bush, the only evidence I've
found that suggests where
the estate got its name.
We march on, crossing Hollywood
Lane in front of Gay
Hill Golf Club, an establishment
that will assume
mythical proportions in my
imagination as a venue for
wife-swapping parties, not that
anyone in my family ever
set foot in the place,
and there was no
truth in the rumor.
Cars flash by at 20 or even
30 miles an hour.
We make it to Highter's Heath
Lane, another main artery of
the neighborhood, which must
be taken if you're visiting
the old Birmingham of nans and
aunts and uncles, recreational
parks and bowling greens.
It gets traversed a lot by the
Taylor family at weekends.
It must also be used by mother
and son if we are to reach our
destination today, Saint
Jude's Parish Church.
I would go to many beautiful,
awe- inspiring churches when I
was older--
St. Patrick's on Fifth Avenue,
St. Peter's in Rome, Notre
Dame de Paris, but St. Jude's on
Glenavon Road was the most
pragmatic people's church
anywhere in the First World.
Built in the post World War II
years, St. Jude's was intended
as a temporary structure,
not meant to last
more than a few years.
It's coming up on 20 now, and
yawning with cold air and
aching joints, single story with
windows every six feet
along its length, and a roof
of corrugated iron.
Its crude purity enhanced the
idea the St. Jude's faithful
had about being the
chosen ones.
Why else would we gather
together in this cold, ugly
place, unless it was an absolute
certainty that we
would benefit from it?
A communal sense of readiness
sends us through the small
lobby, where on raw wooden
tables, literature is offered,
some for sale, some for free--
textbooks, Bibles, songbooks,
and other merchandise,
including rosaries, crucifixes,
and pendants of
St. Jude's, the patron saint
of hopeless cases.
On into the nave, where there
is a smell of sweat and
yesterday's incense.
It's usually cool in here,
sometimes warm, but never hot.
A tall, red-headed man plays a
rickety looking organ, quietly
piping sweet music that
is barely there.
[INAUDIBLE]
would call it ambient.
Candles burn lazily
with a holy scent.
On the strike of 11:00,
the service begins.
The priest enters smartly,
followed by a pair of young
men in white robes, the priest's
team, his posse, one
of whom swings a silver chalice
from which more
incense issues.
The air in the church needs a
good cleansing before the good
father can breathe it.
He wears elaborate clothing, a
robe of green and gold silk
with a red cross on his back.
Beneath the cloak, ankle length
turned up trousers
reveal the black socks and
black robes of any other
working man.
The music surges in volume,
and we all stand.
The red haired man leads us in
a song we know well, The Lord
is My Shepherd.
I open the hymnal to
read the words.
I like this one, but
like Mom, I'm too
embarrassed to sing out loud.
I wish I could.
I just don't.
But I like the feeling of
togetherness that comes from
everyone in the room singing
the same words.
Once the song is over, the
priest walks to the dais.
He glances down at his Bible,
opens his hands wide, and
says, let us pray.
ADAM STEWART: John, you met
Nick, if the chronology I have
is correct, in 1971, so seven
or so years after
this picture is taken.
Music is changing at that time,
and as you guys are
growing up, Bowie, Roxy Music,
and that kind of glam stuff
starts happening.
At '76, there's this turn, it's
the Sex Pistols, so you
get this kind of real
change in music.
'78, Duran Duran comes about.
And you and Nick clearly
have some aspirations.
Some pretty ambitious goals.
At what point in the journey
were you like, we've arrived.
This is it.
This is what we've always
set out to do?
JOHN TAYLOR: Well,
we were lucky.
We connected with a nightclub
in our home city of
Birmingham, and the guys that
ran the club-- that owned it,
actually-- were two brothers.
And it's all about team
building, isn't it, at the end
of the day?
It just is.
I don't believe in solo acts.
It's all about building
a team.
And Nick and I, we were
the founders.
And then we formed Duran, and
we had a couple of guys come
in, and then they left.
Something that I talk about in
the book, how galvanizing it
is when people leave, and they
go on to something else, and
you go, you fuckers!
We're going to show them.
We were written off quite a
few times before we had a
record deal.
And then somebody introduced
us to Roger Taylor, who was
the drummer, and that was when
I started playing bass.
And then it took
us a long time.
I mean, the funny thing about
Duran Duran is, like, I
remember Boy George, he
was a Brummie too.
He spent a lot of time
in Birmingham.
And I remember talking to him at
a wine bar in 1979, and him
saying to me, what's the
name of your band?
And we say, Duran Duran.
He goes, Duran Duran?
Are they still going?
[LAUGHTER]
We bounced around our
town for a while.
We went through different--
finding different--
then you'd find the right--
and then the guitar player--
and then the guitar player
would leave.
But we made the acquaintance
of these two brothers who
became our patrons, and they
started putting a little bit
of money into us, and they gave
us a place to rehearse.
And the group identity
kind of formed
itself in this nightclub.
And then Andy came down
from Newcastle.
He answered an ad in one of the
national music papers, and
he came down.
He was cut from a different
cloth than we were.
He was hardcore.
And he knew his music,
you know?
And then within about six weeks
of him coming-- and I
mean, he came down.
He moved from Newcastle 300
miles to Birmingham, and we
didn't even have a singer.
That's how confident the three
of us and the managers were,
that by the time Simon came on
board, we were like, great,
OK, sign here.
We're off.
And the day that Simon came
in, he walked up to the
microphone.
We were playing.
We'd already been working
on the architecture
of the sound, right?
So we knew what the band's sound
was going to be like,
but we needed a voice.
Simon came in, he got a blue
exercise book that he used to
make notes, like ideas for
poems and whatnot.
I love "Nashville,"
by the way.
I just want to put
that out there.
I think "Nashville" is the best
new show, and I love the
way they address songwriting
and collaboration.
It's smart.
It's really well done.
And Simon had a book with some
words in it, and guys like
that in the music business
are priceless.
There are so few of them.
It's so easy to make a beat, but
somebody comes in with a
decent bit of poetry on
paper, sign them.
Simon walked over to
the microphone and
just, well, try this.
Blah blah blah.
And then that was it.
We were off.
And we said, right.
We've got a gig in four weeks.
Let's write some songs.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM STEWART: I mean, Duran
Duran certainly cut a path
that was different than really,
just about anyone else
at that time, because you
brought together different
factors and things that were
happening in music.
But I'm curious,
because disco.
And you talk a little bit about
Chic in the book and
everything like that, because
there's an aspect of new wave,
and an aspect of disco, and
especially in the early Duran
Duran music.
Can you talk a little bit about
how your sound came
together as a band?
JOHN TAYLOR: Well, I remember
being in a pub one lunchtime
in Birmingham.
I went to art college
for a year, and I
was on my lunch break.
And I remember the jukebox in
the pub, and "Anarchy In the
UK" came on.
Sex Pistols.
That was an anthem for me--
really massive record.
And then Chic came
on after that.
"Everybody Dance,"
I think it was.
And I remember sitting
there thinking, I
love both these songs.
It was like being Republican and
Democrat at the same time.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN TAYLOR: It's like
it was either or.
You can't be both.
And I thought, but I am both.
I love both of those musics.
And I thought, god, if we could
just somehow combine
those two things.
And the key for me was to become
a bass player, because
the thing about Chic's music
and disco music that really
caught my attention
was the bass.
And the music that I've been
listening to-- the bands that
I've been following in my late
teens were bands like The
Clash that were really
guitar-driven.
The bass players just followed
the changes.
Nobody really listened
to the bass.
It was just part of the sound.
But in disco, the bass almost
felt like it was the lead
instrument.
And so I started playing with
Rog, and fortunately, Roger
was also a punk.
But he was kind of like, yeah.
Like "Another One Bites
the Dust," you know?
[HUMMING "ANOTHER ONE
BITES THE DUST"]
You're doing it together,
and it's so much fun.
And then you bring in the big
guitars over the top of that,
and then maybe you've
got something.
And that's kind of like
what we were.
And then at the same time, these
were the days of the
first affordable synthesizers.
I think we got one of the first
Wasp synthesizers which
came into Birmingham.
It was about this big,
it was plastic.
It cost 199 pounds.
And you had to hold it down.
[IMITATING SYNTHESIZER SOUNDS]
And you put a beat to that,
and you've got techno.
ADAM STEWART: Cool.
In the book, you talk a lot
about celebrity, and your
celebrity, and what
you went through.
Talk to us a little bit.
What was the best and the
worst part of celebrity?
JOHN TAYLOR: I think
the best part--
I'm reaping the rewards of it
now, really, because there are
just so many people out
there that care.
When you've been a part of--
I mean, I know how much
Bowie means to me.
There's a handful of guys that
helped me become, that helped
me through that really
difficult time
from 13 to 15, 16.
And I love him like I love
my dad or my wife.
And we had the privilege to
be a part of that for a
generation of teens.
So there are a lot of
people out there
that we're very important.
We play an important part
in their lives.
And it's very useful when you
want to get a table in a
restaurant.
No, but that's a great thing.
The worst thing--
I don't know.
I mean, I feel like you're
suspended in adolescence,
which is fun, but
it's also bad.
Because I think I got to the age
of 30, and just the sight
of a bill coming through
my post freaked me out.
I just didn't know what to
do with a telephone bill.
You just don't know.
I guess a lot of athletes have
that, too, because you're just
treated like babies.
It's just about, no, you just
concentrate on playing,
writing songs, and performing,
and looking
good for the video.
That's all you've got to do.
We'll take care of
everything else.
But there's certain things that
as adults, we need to be
able to take care of.
And when the boat slows down,
the train slows down, and then
you're in a position where
you go, you know what?
Maybe I need to start taking
care of that, and that, and
doing that.
But it's kind of overwhelming.
So maybe that's the worst.
ADAM STEWART: Cool.
I think it's a good point for us
to maybe hear a little bit
more from the book.
JOHN TAYLOR: OK.
This is a shorter one, honest.
Chapter 31, Legal Age.
This is Duran Duran on their
first trip to Los Angeles,
photographed in Boystown, in
fact, although nobody told us
we were in Boystown
at the time.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN TAYLOR: Chapter
31, Legal Age.
One thing I discovered on tour
in 1981 was that girls, in all
languages, like taking
drugs with me.
Even though I had a girlfriend
back home, my horror of lonely
hotel rooms meant I would go
to any lengths to avoid
sleeping in them alone.
Coke, I was beginning to
realize, was an effective
insurance policy against
that eventuality.
I'd been a nerd at school.
I wasn't a jock or an
intellectual, and I'd never
had a regular girlfriend
as a teenager.
Now I only had to wink in a
girl's direction in a hotel
lobby, backstage, or at a record
company party, and I
have company until
the morning.
So what's the problem,
you might ask?
Well, the trouble is-- and I
didn't figure this out until I
was almost 40--
that there's something about an
intimate encounter of that
nature with someone you
barely know that
jars against the spirit.
You want it, but it doesn't
feel quite right.
And when you start doing it
night after night, week in,
week out, your ideas about
love and sex begin to get
somewhat distorted.
And jumping into bed like porn
star Johnny is not as easy as
you might imagine, especially
with someone whose first name
you're not even sure of.
You feel awkward, or
at least I do.
Maybe it was some residue
of Catholic guilt.
Plain old common decency?
Hadn't mother taught me
something about this?
The drugs and the alcohol served
to take away all those
doubts, plus any inhibitions
or insecurities I
or she might have.
I didn't want to be lonely,
and the drugs
ensured I never was.
I'm a pinup on thousands of
bedroom walls, but the fear of
loneliness is turning
me into a cokehead.
Of absolute necessity
for any touring
musician is the itinerary.
It usually comes as a gift from
the tour manager on the
last day of rehearsal.
Depending on the length of the
tour about to be undertaken,
it could cover any length
of time between one
week and two months.
Page one lists the principals--
the inner circle--
the crew who are going to get
the show around the world.
All the numbers to call if in
trouble are listed there-- the
management, the agencies,
the travel
agents, the local promoters.
Then follows a page by page
account of the destinations.
October 3rd, Chicago.
Band hotel, Ambassador East.
Crew hotel, Crown Hyatt.
Venue, Park West, and
so on and so on.
I'd not noticed right away that
in the left hand corner
of each page of the US
itinerary, there was a number--
usually 18, 20, or 21.
It was months before I was
let in on the secret.
The numbers referred to the
legal age for sexual
intercourse in that
particular state.
The other necessity for the
touring musician is the day
sheet, usually slipped under the
hotel room door while the
occupant is still asleep.
Regardless of the degree of
befuddlement, the day sheet
information was always
quite clear.
Today is October 3rd, it is
Friday, you are in Chicago.
Today is a show day.
Sound check is at 4:00 PM.
You almost expected it to
say, your name is John.
[LAUGHTER]
ADAM STEWART: That's awesome.
So I think at that point in
the book, too, you start
talking a little bit more, and
it comes up even in that
chapter, this kind of notion
of loneliness.
And it's now kind of being
equated to drugs and alcohol
becoming a larger part
of your life.
Was that a cause and effect?
Was it the loneliness and then
what you were kind of feeling
on the road that led
you to that point?
JOHN TAYLOR: Well, I'm still
figuring it out, really.
I mean, getting to write a book
like this, you really do
analyze your behavior,
and the whys.
I was the guy in the band
that just didn't
have the off switch.
I mean, it could be 5:00 in the
morning and everybody else
was turning in, because
we had a travel day or
whatever the next--
I'd just be getting started.
And you become the guy.
We've all got one
in our family.
Every family's got one.
Uncle Jake just doesn't
know how to put
the plug in the jug.
Just doesn't know
when to stop.
And when you are that guy, you
start getting a lot of shame.
Over the years, you're
the hung over one.
You're the butt of the joke.
And I'm not sure what that
loneliness was about.
I think it was a combination
of things.
I mean, fame is very--
you've got a lot of
people around
you giving you attention.
It's very addictive.
I mean, it's very hard
to turn off from.
And I found it to be quite an
insecure world, actually.
We had a couple of good years,
but then paranoia set in, and
the drugs didn't help that.
Hangover wont'--
when you're late for the
meeting, what's the first
thing you think?
What have they been
saying about me?
ADAM STEWART: There's some
pretty harrowing stories in
the book, you know?
All nighters, and--
JOHN TAYLOR: What's that?
ADAM STEWART: All nighters,
and some wild times.
When did you realize that
you had a problem?
When did you decide to do
something about it?
JOHN TAYLOR: Well, I
think any of us--
when do you realize
you're an addict?
When do you realize you're
addicted to shopping or
cigarettes?
When you try to stop.
And often, we put that off.
We say, yeah, yeah, I could
stop if I wanted to.
I just choose not to.
So then my late 20s, I tried
to stop spending.
I tried to stop shagging.
I tried to stop getting high.
All of these things.
And I've got no program.
I've got no idea how to do it.
And it's really hard.
I found that I guess
I was living in LA.
I've moved to LA.
I'd had a child.
I'm 30, I think, now.
In my early 30s.
And by that point, I'd gotten
kind of unhappy, and I felt
that I'd blown it.
The early '80s were great
for the band.
The second half of the '80s,
we were hanging on.
Hanging on like the fucking
zeitgeist was over there, and
it was like, maybe you guys
should just call it a day.
We were like, we were just
getting started.
MTV didn't want to play us.
Nobody wanted to play
us on the radio.
And that's when you really
have to dig in.
I mean, that's when people start
saying to you, well, you
don't really need to work
anymore, do you?
It's like, what are you
supposed to do?
I never get that argument,
because I love my job.
So I'm not looking to take
an early retirement.
But we hung in there.
But yeah, I wanted
to talk about it.
I talk about getting sober in
the book, because that was
profound for me.
And I was really lucky.
I just happened to meet the
right person at the right time
who directed me to rehab.
And I thought, rehab?
I'm not one of those
guys, am I?
But it really worked for me.
And I wanted that to
be in the book.
I wanted to find a way to write
about that, because it
enabled me to have a life, on
top of all the fun and games
of the '80s.
ADAM STEWART: Hard to
look back at that?
Hard to tell that story?
JOHN TAYLOR: Which bit?
ADAM STEWART: Just the kind of
darker times, and that aspect
of it, as you're kind of going
back and looking over your
life and seeing all of these
different things that have
happened and occurred.
JOHN TAYLOR: Yeah, I knew that
there was going to be a
recovery element to the book.
I knew that--
that if I was going to do a
book, I was going to have to
find a way of describing the
experience that I had with
rehab, and the makeover that
I got as a result of it.
But then what that meant was,
I was going to have to show
the reader why I needed
to go to rehab.
So there was going to have to be
a handful of scenes, and I
was going to have to take the
reader down and get a sense of
what it was like.
But I feel like I found
a way of doing it.
I mean, spiritual journey is
one of the undercurrents in
the book, because it starts out,
like, the first reading
that I did, my mother was
very religious, but I
never bought into that.
I think at the peak of my real
waste out time was the mid
'80s, and I had an apartment on
the Upper West Side of New
York and I used to get so high
in that place, and a lot of
all nighters.
And there's a scene that
I always remembered.
There was a storm, and I was
really, really messed up,
Quentin Tarantino style.
And what did I do
at 9 o'clock?
I want to call my parish priest,
because I've decided
that I need to write
a [INAUDIBLE]
for Saint Jude's.
It wasn't calling hookers.
I'm calling my fucking parish
priest, who I haven't spoken
to in three years.
And I thought that was
really kind of
interesting that I did that.
And if I could write that
scene, I thought
that would be different.
It might give a key to who
I was, rather than--
I never called in hookers,
actually, I'm happy to say.
That never appealed to me.
But I was looking for some kind
of spiritual salvation,
even after three years--
three or four years of using.
ADAM STEWART: It's kind of
interesting to hear that
connectedness to home.
We did a Google Hangout before,
and for as much as the
varied questions, a lot of
people came back to one of the
themes that really comes out in
the book, which is really
your connectedness to your
parents, and that type of
inspiration, and how your
parents-- both of them have
passed away, but what that meant
to you in your life.
So it's really interesting to
hear that at the time, where
everything is kind of going
crazy in your life in New
York, you're still thinking
about back home.
And I think that was one of
those things, again, that I
just feel connected with a
lot of different people.
30 years now, plus, I think,
into Duran Duran.
What's it like for you today?
JOHN TAYLOR: It's good.
It's good.
I'm glad I got to write the
book over the last year,
because we've had a
really good time.
I mean, we did our
last album as a
digital download on iTunes.
It felt like we finally got
right with new media.
For a couple of years, we
just couldn't relate.
We couldn't find our place
in the industry.
And this last album,
we were lucky.
Mark Ronson stepped in
and produced, and
he gave us a sense--
just having in the room,
you feel hipper.
I mean, that was a good thing.
And then we started getting into
social media, networking,
promoting the album, and finding
what that did for the
connectivity of our fans
was just amazing.
And I felt it.
I mean, the album came out just
before Christmas of 2010,
at the end of not last year,
the year before.
And we started getting into
social networking.
And the first show that we did
was in London about three
months later.
And the feeling in the room
was so charged up.
It was completely different to
anything that we'd done in the
previous five years.
And I put that down to
social networking.
And people were showing up, and
they were going, hey, how
are you doing?
And they'd connected, because
when the band goes on social
networking, people start signing
on, following us on
Twitter, getting onto Facebook,
and they start
connecting.
And suddenly, it's like
Duran fans reunited.
It's like one of those
friend networks.
And it's generated a lot of
energy around the band.
And I don't even worry about
getting in the charts anymore.
It's not about that.
It's just, like, we've got
this really strong family
that's kind of re-committed
itself to each other, and
actually is kind of
growing again.
So it's been an interesting
couple of years.
And we're going to get back and
do another album with Mark
in the spring.
And we're really enjoying
our music.
ADAM STEWART: Terriffic.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Who are your current
musical inspirations?
JOHN TAYLOR: I was playing
Led Zeppelin yesterday.
They're never not going
to be relevant.
I've been listening to a lot of
folk rock lately, actually.
Bert Jansch, John Renbourn.
Sort of old English
guitar music.
But I like modern music.
I like to hear great
modern music.
[INAUDIBLE]
is a DJ that I really like,
and he's put an album out.
It's like a curated DJ set
that's kind of like my album
of choice at the moment.
You just have to look.
Like last year, I was on the
road in England, and I was
listening to Louis Armstrong.
I thought, this is what
it's come to.
I'm listening to music
from the '30s.
That's how crap contemporary
music is.
And I just chanced upon this
record store called Piccadilly
Records in Manchester.
I went in-- it was December, and
they'd curated the year's
best music, and they printed
up a pamphlet.
You know, Amoeba do it, Rough
Trade do it in London.
And they printed up a pamphlet,
and all the staff
from the record store got to
write a little blurb about
what they thought was
the important best
music of the year.
And I'm opening up this
pamphlet, and almost every one
of them is saying, wow, the
best music of 2011--
I don't know where to begin.
It was such a fantastic
year for music.
And I'm thinking, fantastic
year for music?
And I realized how out
of touch I was.
And I bought half
a dozen albums.
Their top six albums
of the year.
Every one of them--
Kurt Vile, Washed
Out, Metronomy.
I mean, half a dozen bands that
I'd not heard of became
my new favorite bands.
So I just have to
get out there.
If I want to be into
contemporary music, I just
have to make an effort.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I sort of have a
follow-up question to that,
for music discovery.
For your own music that you
listen to, do you find
yourself using digital services,
like you said, going
to record stores?
And if you are using digital
services, are you using
Spotify, or YouTube,
or iTunes?
JOHN TAYLOR: Yeah.
I mean, I'm on the hunt all the
time for music that I have
not heard before.
It doesn't have to be new.
It can be old.
But something that's going
to inspire me--
that's going to keep
me interested.
I find that as a bass player,
I can only listen to
contemporary music for so long,
because most of the
great bass work is older.
But I've always got a stack
of stuff that I'm
working my way through.
I do use iTunes if there's
something that I need now.
But if it's something that's
important to me, I'm still
attached to the physical
product.
I've sort of gotten back into
vintage vinyl the way some
people get into vintage wines.
I mean, the idea of taking
"Exile on Main St." out maybe
once every two years,
and putting it on--
that's like uncorking a vintage
bottle of wine.
I just want to do it, and then
I don't want to hear it for
another two years.
Because music, like any art,
it doesn't have infinite
amounts of energy in it.
You have to pace yourself
in your
appreciation of it, I find.
I also found-- we were talking
over lunch how the music, like
those three bands that I just
mentioned, I still am attached
to imagery.
Like, I still like packaging
that gives me something more,
something visual that I can
connect with the music that
I'm listening to.
And I find that if it's music
that I'm going around telling
everybody, you've got
to get this band!
You've got to buy this!
Then I own that physical
product.
I've got to have it.
I've got to have something
that I can
relate to on that level.
I haven't been able to
let go of that yet.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Can you fill us in on
how you guys came up with
the name Duran Duran?
JOHN TAYLOR: Yeah.
It's from the film "Barbarella"
with Jane Fonda
as the sexy lady astronaut.
It was taken from a French
cartoon strip, and
the film is a really--
Roger Vadim.
It's a really extraordinary
film.
It's beautifully shot,
kind of kitsch.
And I think the opening line in
the film is Barbarella, you
must find Duran Duran from
the planet Earth.
That's the opening
line in the film.
And Duran Duran is this
criminal, this sort of
trans-universal criminal who has
stolen some machine that
is guaranteed to give
women pleasure.
But that had nothing to do
with that choice of name.
[LAUGHTER]
I mean, it was just a time
when everybody was naming
their band The something.
The Damned, The Boys,
The Clash.
So I liked the idea
that this had
something that seemed modern.
AUDIENCE: Do you have a favorite
Duran Duran album or
single or video?
JOHN TAYLOR: Well, I think "Rio"
is probably the album
that's just where we really
caught the wave.
And I think every note
of it works.
Better than works.
Every note of it is great.
But I'm proud of a lot.
I'm proud of "Ordinary World"
as a song very much.
"Notorious."
"View To A Kill." You know,
that's interesting.
Writing a Bond theme is like
designing a Rolls Royce.
It's really, really difficult,
because you've got so many
boxes you have to tick for
it to work for the Bond
franchise, but I think we did
a really good job with that.
And that was a difficult
song to write.
There was a lot of infighting
going on while we were doing
it, but I'm really happy
with that one.
AUDIENCE: That was a
cool video, too.
JOHN TAYLOR: You think so?
See, I hate that video.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Wow.
JOHN TAYLOR: It's not
one of my favorites.
I'd rather watch the
titles from the
film unfurl, you know?
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ADAM STEWART: Any
other questions?
Great.
Terrific.
AUDIENCE: Have you tried playing
your song on "Rock
Band?"
JOHN TAYLOR: No!
No!
Never.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: And do you get--
because they change
the level, right.
Some songs are harder
than others.
Do you appreciate it if
your song is the easy
song or the hard song?
JOHN TAYLOR: No.
You could be talking to me
about brain surgery.
I know nothing about
"Rock Band."
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering if you
can kind of paint a picture
for us of what it was like, the
first public performance
that you did as the Fab Five
lineup with Simon.
What was that night like?
Was it a disaster,
or was it magic--
everything came together?
JOHN TAYLOR: Well, again, we've
got to go back to the
club that we were based out of,
which was a club called
the Rum Runner in Birmingham.
And it was a very culty
kind of scene.
It was a very fashion-oriented
scene.
It was kind of post punk, and
it was this kind of glamor
that was coming back.
It was very ambiguous,
sexually.
There was a lot of gays
on the scene.
People were just into
dressing up.
Everybody did something
with their hair--
dyed, coiffed, whatever.
And it was like a kind
of oasis, really.
A post-punk oasis.
And the kind of music that was
popular there was this sort of
new electronic vibe,
like Simple Minds,
Japan, bands like that.
And so we became the
house band there.
And we were rehearsing there.
And we all had jobs there.
We would all work behind the
bar, or work on the door.
And in return for that, the
owners had given us this--
we had a rehearsal space
just off the main bar.
And on a Friday night, which was
a really hot night in the
club, we'd go up and turn on our
gear, and we'd invite some
of our friends up at midnight,
and we'd just play some songs
while everybody was dancing
down on the floor.
So when we had the final debut,
as I call it, which was
like version five of the band,
we were playing to friends.
And everybody kind of knew us.
And there was a sense of, like,
OK, these are our guys.
This is our band.
It's not like a foot
stomping kind of--
it's not like, a yeah
kind of scene.
It was like, hmm, okay,
yeah, cool.
And yeah.
I mean, there are one or two
pictures from that particular
show in the book, in fact.
I'll point them out
to you afterwards.
Thanks.
ADAM STEWART: Any
other questions?
AUDIENCE: What was going on
the band when Arcadia--
kind of the branch out there?
Were you guys broken up, or--
JOHN TAYLOR: Yeah.
I mean, I feel, in a way,
we kind of had.
I mean, it's funny.
The pressure was so great in the
early, mid '80s, just to
write big hits.
And we kind of--
we weren't all agreeing
on the direction
the band should take.
So when we finished the third
album, Andy and I decided we
wanted to do a side project.
And so over time, we connected
with Robert Palmer, Tony
Thompson, Bernard Edwards, the
rhythm section from Chic, and
we made that album.
And then Simon, Nick, and Roger
kind of countered that
with Arcadia.
I mean, it was difficult.
Nine months, maybe, where we
were very much-- there were
two camps, and that's
in the book.
Because we were kind of fighting
with the managers,
and it wasn't a happy
time, really.
It was quite difficult.
But it's in there.
Any more for any more?
ADAM STEWART: I think that's
a good question to segue,
actually, into the
last reading.
JOHN TAYLOR: OK.
We got to play Coachella last
year, and it was a big one for
me, because I've got kids.
I've got teenage kids that
have been telling me for
years, you guys got to
play Coachella, man.
It was like final validation
with the teenagers.
But it was magical.
It was magical.
So I chose to end the
book on that night.
Behind the stage, to the
side of the ramp,
our band has gathered.
We stepped off the pair of golf
carts that had brought us
the half mile from our dressing
room in battery
powered silence.
The air is warm and
electric blue.
We acknowledge each other
without words, using nods and
smiles, back slaps, and other
gestures of encouragement.
Instincts surge.
Every other concern
falls away.
Since 1981, we've released our
songs on vinyl, cassette tape,
CD, 8 track, digital audio tape,
mini disc, ringtones,
MP3, streaming, and download,
for purchase or rental.
I've long since learned to relax
and cease worrying about
how the music finds its
way to your ears.
Just play.
Just write.
By the time we begin the "All
You Need Is Now" tour, which
tonight's performance at
Coachella is a part of,
excitement levels have
reached fever pitch.
We've come a long way to get to
this holy place, Coachella,
and a lot has changed in
the last 30 years.
Cell phones, computers, SUVs,
nose hair trimmers,
supplements, Propecia, paperless
itineraries, in-room
humidifiers, steam rooms,
saunas, and gyms, pre-show
massage, Twitter, Spotify,
and Google.
Touring with 3,000 songs in my
pocket and 30 books on an
iPad, therapy by Skype, great
coffee everywhere.
Another difference is out there,
where there are just as
many men as women in the
audience tonight.
At day's end, my job is to be
a catalyst for connectivity,
to help bring people closer
together, men and
women, girls and boys.
That's what the music
has done for me.
What hasn't changed are the
notes that run up and down the
neck of the bass and the feeling
that hits you when one
note rubs against another in a
way that sets the hair up on
the back of your neck, and the
sound of the crowd, and the
feeling of adrenaline that
charges through my body when I
hear it holding that
four-stringed machine gun on
stage less than six feet
away from you.
Simon is running through his
vocal warmups which we so
often rib him about.
Nick has a plastic cup in his
left hand, and is taking sips
from it, now reaching his right
hand upward to flash a
snapshot on his camera.
We all fiddle with our in-ear
monitors, trying the volume,
listening for interference.
A photographer from
"Spin Magazine"
wants to take a picture.
We assemble reluctantly,
everyone just wanting to get
on with the show.
It's an outdoor festival, so
tour manager Craig will not
get to give his usual cue to
take the house lights down.
Tonight, that is one of
God's jobs, and what a
job of it he is doing.
A glittering bauble of sunlight
fights to stay above
the horizon.
A full moon appears, a
late-coming VIP that takes a
seat above the lighting gantry
at 11 o'clock high.
Nature presents for us a better
light show than any
human could ever have created.
We walk together up the ramp.
The stage is set, the
electronics are primed, the
audience ready.
Nick walks on first in
a black net snood
borrowed from Lady Gaga.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN TAYLOR: He walks across the
stage and onto his riser,
puts down his camera, and
touches the Andromeda
synthesizer from which issues
forth a sample of the exact
sound he used to begin our first
single, "Planet Earth,"
written and recorded
over 30 years ago.
My heart is pounding.
There is no better time than
this, and I'm about to take
the stage, and the future
belongs to me.
This is what the moment feels
like as I walk out onto the
stage one more time.
Roger's drums kick in, an eight
bar count, and I'm in
with him, the galloping groove
that started it all for me.
30,000 California kids, eyes and
teeth smiling, cameras and
cell phones popping, a million
tiny seductions all at once,
and the music never
sounded better.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM STEWART: John.
On behalf of Google, thank you
very much for doing this.
That was really terrific.
So John's going to be signing
books right outside.
Thanks, everybody.